this week on ford founder and ceo of
good information inc and courier
newsroom tara mcgowan joins us to talk
misinformation and what we can do about
it this week on forward
[Music]
[Music]
it's my pleasure to welcome to ford
civic entrepreneur the founder and ceo
of good information
and the courier newsroom which we're
going to talk about uh at length tara
mcgowan welcome tara thanks so much for
having me andrew it's great to be here
oh tara you're working on a problem so
we'll retrace your steps so people have
a sense of your background which is
fascinating but you're working on a
problem that's near and dear to my heart
uh which is the fact that local news is
dying
you have over 2 000 local papers that
have gone out of business you probably
know the numbers better than i do and
they've probably gotten worse since i
looked at it
so what what is the situation with local
news
yeah it's it's really really bleak
andrew as you mentioned
it got significantly worse during the
pandemic as you can imagine the
shuttering of newsrooms and you know
writ large this has been happening for
over a decade now and it's really
the result of local news organizations
having relied on one specific stream of
revenue which was advertising
traditional advertising um in their
newspapers local
and regional advertisers and you know as
the advertising industry got entirely
uh imploded and revolutionized by big
tech and social media platforms also
known as craigslist and facebook but
continue yes exactly
local news organizations who were
already struggling to get by with
resources couldn't keep up couldn't
evolve their business models quickly
enough so what's been happening is
they're either shutting down or
sometimes worse they're getting bought
up by hedge funds that are buying them
up for different pieces selling them off
um just focusing on how to monetize them
and laying off the journalists and
um and not really investing in the
mission any longer of these of these
organizations and institutions
and the the really scary part i mean it
won it's just terrible for people not to
have access to local information yes in
their communities how can you have a
functioning democracy if you don't know
what the heck's going on that's right or
just a functioning society right i mean
we
we are still going through a pandemic
and interest in local information was at
its highest during the early months of
the pandemic because
the information was all over the place
right states and uh and municipalities
were making decisions different than the
federal government and so people didn't
know you know what what the rules were
in their state when it came to schools
and school openings and closures and
mass mandates and yet there there is so
limited local information that's
available and trusted to your point on
democracy there's a direct correlation
between access to trustworthy local
information and civic participation so
when you don't have access to that
information you're less likely to
participate
why would you vote if there's no one
who's even telling you who's running
what the issues are that's right that's
right and if you're relying on national
media to do that they're focused
no they're focused on a totally
different audience that has a you know a
different agenda they're focused on high
information elite coastal
information news consumers and so
they're talking about horse races and
they're talking about really you know
and they tend to be much more uh
polarizing and political that's right
that's exactly right they nationalize
everything right and so you're not
really understanding the impacts of
policy decisions or candidates positions
or platforms on yourself your family or
community at all at that level yeah one
of the things i love about local news is
it tends to be less ideological less
partisan because if you're going to talk
about high school sports or the bridge
being rebuilt i mean there are only so
many ways to
[Laughter]
kind of frame that information
um so let's now retrace your steps uh
the people who've been listening to me
in the podcast know that i've been
deeply concerned about the
the death or near death of local papers
of the last number of years and i think
it's
completely messed up that as a country
we haven't taken
greater measures to try and combat that
i mean you're actually devoting all of
your energies and waking time to trying
to make that uh problem better which you
know uh one reason i'm so excited to sit
down with you
but you started your career i wanna say
uh in tv news and then got bitten by the
political bug
uh when uh obama ran for president
that's right i was a journalist i went
to journalism school here in new york um
and i started my career at 60 minutes
which was
uh really an incredible experience
really educational formative um it's
still you know a really unique news
magazine
they were number one in the ratings for
a long time as i don't know if that's
still the case i don't know if they're
still number one but i know that they
still reach younger people increasingly
like they're still really kind of the
the gold standard of journalism that
crosses generations it's it's pretty
incredible because they haven't changed
their format at all um which really
defies a lot of the industry um in terms
of being able to survive but it was an
incredible experience in a lot of ways
it was also a mixed bag working for
corporate media and i'm sure some of
your listeners have heard things about
cbs news over the years so i worked
there during that but um overall i i i
was uh lucky to be on the team that
covered the 2008 presidential election
i did get very swept up and then senator
obama's candidacy and i made the
decision in 2009 late 2009 to leave
journalism and try my hat at politics
and move to dc cold and started a career
in democratic politics that
i went on to do for about over a decade
wow so you moved down there
to try and help
move the country in a positive direction
after obama became president and obama
was something of a
magnet for people who wanted to try and
be of service
in some way i have friends who moved to
dc uh either to become part of the
administration or otherwise
uh i remember when obama won i mean that
was like uh
a real
cause for celebration uh uh in
you know here in new york and uh among
my friends
so
uh you worked in democratic politics and
uh you became kind of a heavyweight in
reaching large numbers of people through
digital
campaigns uh you worked on the hillary
campaign i want to say in some capacity
no not the campaign um i worked on the
ie side so the independent expenditure
side i worked for priorities usa in
2016. the largest super pac on the left
my husband worked on the campaign so we
actually were firewalled from each other
how did that go we got married during
that campaign and so our lawyers
actually did get on a call about whether
we needed ndas at our very small wedding
because there were people from both
sides but uh it worked out because we
never spoke so we were living in
different places both preoccupied with
the election so um but yeah i was on the
super pac side i ran
a 42 million dollar digital advertising
program against trump um obviously it
was it was not enough no one thing is
anyhow but i learned a lot in the
process and
it was my first role really having a
seat at the table of you know senior
level democratic operatives i'd been
really lucky to do a lot of jobs i'd
worked on the obama campaign in 2012 um
doing production and video production
and digital video storytelling and then
i was put in this role of priorities and
uh and it was a fantastic opportunity
because they they they'd always been an
organization that focused entirely on
traditional media and really negative
advertising so television mail um radio
uh really kind of you know taking one
for the team on the the independent dark
money side to do kind of the negative
work against mitt romney in 2012 and
other things and
i was given the opportunity to
envision what a digital
program and department would look like
there and so
it was a really exciting opportunity i
got to build my own team
but i also was pretty horrified as i
learned how much power consultants had
in democratic politics and in politics
generally
and i'm talking about everyone from
posters to traditional media consultants
and even digital consultants who i
worked with at the time
there there just was there was a level
of hubris
just in sort of that community and not
feeling a need or any incentive to
innovate or experiment with new
strategies or tactics and
i really felt in that role before the
election that we were falling behind and
not really staying up to speed on how
the platforms like facebook and
instagram were evolving so so quickly
and and how trump in particular was was
really taking advantage of these tools
in a way that that our consultants
weren't encouraging us to do the same
wow so you had a front row seat to the
the fact that hey maybe the democratic
machinery wasn't uh keeping pace yeah
and it was it was really disheartening
because i came out of the obama campaign
and culture that was incredibly
empowering to younger people on the
campaign and to digital strategy and so
i think that it really was a little bit
of just resting on the laurels of that
we don't need to innovate we are the
ones who are good at digital and yet the
the technology was changing so quickly
and gaining so much more years as an
eternity in this case
one year can be an eternity if you don't
keep up to speed on the changing
algorithms and policies and ad tech
stacks like you you really don't know
what you're doing and so i got told all
the time to just trust the consultants
and if i hear anyone just tell me to
trust them my like spidey senses go up
and so i started to to peel away more of
the work in-house from the consultants
and that kind of turned into the model i
ended up starting an organization around
in 2017 called acronym which was a 501c4
committed to increasing investment
experimentation innovation
in digital outreach to increase civic
participation ultimately and to support
progressive causes in candidates so
let's unpack this consultant line of
thought
because i've met and worked with a lot
of consultants
and one of the tough things about the
consultants
is that
they kind of
coalesce around a particular campaign uh
and then they move on to the next one
and so would they prefer to win sure
right
yeah like uh it is
is it an existential
threat for them no uh because if they're
consulting at a really high level
it might be their seventh or seventeenth
campaign uh you know and and so
is there going to be an 18th campaign
for them yes
um and so what it reminds me of for
people who are into sports it's like an
nfl head coach who's much better off
losing
by seven points professionally
that's right they're trying to do
something
uh out of the box and then maybe losing
by 20. that's right but maybe giving
yourself a chance to win that's right
there's a there's a lot of failing up
there's very little accountability uh
because you know the same way you can't
take credit even though many folks do
for winning an entire election based on
one strategy or tactic you also can't
take the fall necessarily uh for for a
campaign losing based on a strategy or
tact tech and that was that was really
enlightening to me because i i really
was uh very idealistic i was like aren't
we all in this together don't we all
want to win
right don't we want to throw anything
and everything at the wall um and and
also at the time in 2016 there you know
there was and this wasn't unique to my
team organization at all there was
really a very very deep and broad sense
that hillary had it in the bag sure um
people were already just picking out
jobs for themselves right that's right
and i you know
for the years and years that i had done
this work i never ever once believed any
campaign that i was working on or
working on behalf of was was issuing
because
um one you really there's so much we
just don't know ever to be honest i mean
we know that polls are broken we so the
information that you have is is really
fraught to begin with and and also it's
just not a way to motivate yourself to
try and think uh you know around
quarters and what the other side is
doing because they're tireless and
ruthless and so
it was just it was a really eye-opening
experience for me i became somebody
invited into rooms of donors and leaders
in the party whose hair was on fire
about how this could have happened
after 2016 and i didn't have you know
the answers but i i was able to shed
some light on on what we weren't doing
when it came to leveraging tools like
facebook and thinking outside the box on
reaching voters and
um and also just
democrats you know this is this is not a
hot take they've always had a messaging
problem a little bit and there's a lot
of reasons for that but i was just
really frustrated at how out of touch
folks felt with people sure
and
if they lose they blame the voters half
the time it's like oh like you know
these voters so that's right immoral or
wrong-headed it's like well maybe your
goal should be to try and
uh figure out where people are and then
win these things and then deliver do
some listening right and and i think
that was part of the pieces that the the
being out of touch of of where people
were and how they were feeling and what
they were concerned about or frustrated
with or anxious about it started to
extend to where they were actually
getting their information
we were you know continuing to spend and
democrats still do
hundreds of millions of dollars on
television advertisements that are
reaching an
an increasingly tiny slice of the
electorate of regular older
whiter voters
while you may or may not be able to
convince or push you know like they're
like that's right their their attitude
or vote might be fixed that's right so
it just it felt like
it felt like walking into a house where
everything was upside down and feeling
like am i the crazy one no no you were
the same one for sure
and you decided to do something about it
which is awesome
[Music]
all right folks we all know it this
economy sucks and if you've got a small
business this inflation situation isn't
doing you any favors right now it's
harder than ever to stay profitable so
if you're looking for a way to cut costs
mailing and shipping is a great place to
start and that's why we use stamps.com
to mail and ship and get access to
exclusive discounts at great rates on
shipping from usps and ups it's easy and
awesome stamps.com saves you time money
and stress for more than 20 years
they've been doing this they've been
indispensable for over 1 million
businesses including ours stamps.com
gives you access to all the post office
and ups shipping services you need right
from your computer and discounts you
can't find anywhere else no matter what
business you're in stamps.com can help
you save on shippings without sending
invoices or etsy shops sending your
products or warehouse shipping out
truckloads of orders stamps.com is a
mailing shipping solution for you so
here's the deal so i want you guys to
start mailing and start shipping with
stamps.com and keep more money in your
pocket every stinking day especially in
today's economy with high inflation and
costs are utmost important so sign up
with the promo code yang for a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long term commitments or contracts at
all so just go to stamps.com click the
microphone at the top of the page and
enter code yang
[Music]
i i do want to dig into this a little
bit more just because it's something
a lot of americans feel so so that the
democratic party
um does have a messaging problem
uh
the loss to donald trump in 2016 um in
in my mind uh was born of like a lot of
issues but uh but a lot of it was that
people were counting their chickens
before they're hatched and thinking like
we have this in the bag and like let's
figure out who's gonna sit in what chair
uh uh afterwards
and then when hillary lost to trump um
you didn't really feel like there was
like a reckoning or people coming
together and being like hey like what
what's what's wrong with
uh us
that we could lose to this guy uh you
know i mean
and this got me to a point where i
decided to run for president where i was
like hey i think i can contribute he's
going to say you did something too yeah
thanks yeah yeah that's good fun
um
and so then uh joe biden uh eeks out a
win against trump in 2020 and people
should know how close that race was it
was not a landslide yeah i mean it's 44
000 votes in uh three or four swing
states
um
uh and that there is the this sense
still that uh democrats haven't
necessarily learned or evolved i mean
that there is also this fractious nature
of the party uh in terms of trying to
legislate where anyone who has been
paying attention this past
number of months has gotten this like oh
no like that you know this team doesn't
seem to have it like fully together and
they're not
really really deliberate um we all feel
like they're going to get wrecked in
november which uh will probably happen
uh and then if trump runs again
uh like do you trust the democrats to
defeat them to defeat trump in in 24
it's like i don't i mean looking at it's
like is there like an excellent chance
that
democrats lose not once but twice
to trump um in part because i feel like
the lessons learned
um haven't really been taken uh to heart
so this these are some of the things
that motivate me i'm not sure how many
of these thoughts you've had but you
decided to to then try and solve some of
the problems and say okay i'm going to
start an organization that does things
the way that i think people would be
excited about yeah and and i want to i
want to get back to kind of your
your sort of thoughts on where things
are going and where they could go in 22
and 24 because i think i might have a
little bit more optimism than you but
it's not based on the democratic party
it's actually based on the american
people but we can circle back i do like
the american people
if they have access to good information
we'll get there and are empowered and
feel empowered um but
but yeah i mean you're not wrong that a
lot of lessons hadn't been heeded i do
think
i do think that there were
constellations of really exciting
innovation and startup organizations
that didn't exist before 2016. there was
a flurry of them that came out of the
woodwork that were not sanctioned by the
party or the party leaders who really
run the infrastructure right and i think
that's where the lessons haven't
necessarily been internalized is in
those organizations and those
institutions on the party side um but
the really exciting part after 2016 were
that organizations like indivisible and
swing left an acronym that i started
they they popped up and they didn't have
to be sort of blessed we just kind of
were disruptive and we did it and the
other thing that happened was that a lot
of people that had never funded
political work especially democratic
political work started to be like
terrified when trump was elected and
wanting to get involved a lot of folks
from silicon valley which was
controversial and written about and
things of that nature but i mean i
certainly benefited from some of that
new energy and resources acronym did
because those folks came in they want
understood technology and how
information flowed online and they also
were more inclined to take risks i'm
friendly with some of these people and
i love the fact that they
stepped up and did something about it
and the fact they funded you so so the
the individuals i'm thinking of are reid
hoffman and lauren powell jobs both of
whom i like and admire yeah they're
they're both wonderful and reid has been
a very strong supporter and backer and
is still my lead investor at good
information inc to this day and um you
know
he's he he invested in this work for
absolutely the right mission-driven
reasons but also was unafraid to take
risks and also
encouraged failure because failure is
how we learn and there's this risk
aversion in politics and democratic
politics i can't speak to republican
i've never worked in the republican
party or do i ever see that happening um
but there's i mean the republican party
is
losing its
[ __ ]
right what is the republican party today
right it's and and so i
i really appreciated that because the
risk aversion and the over reliance on
on polling and micro targeting it's like
you just miss the forest through like
for the trees right you're not actually
you know listening to instincts or
trying new ways of approaching this and
we live in a really disruptive age
across the board you you can't compete
if you don't experiment if you don't
throw things at the wall if you don't
get scrappy and if you don't take risks
and if you don't make mistakes so for
people who don't know reed hoffman's
background he was uh the founder of
linkedin uh he was also one of the
founding members of paypal
um and so they they've tried a lot of it
yeah but they've tried a lot of things
that haven't worked it's put it that way
you know and so so
a lot of things that have that have made
a very very very wealthy man yeah yeah
so but you know and then when they find
something that does work they lean into
it um so you know i so i completely
applaud uh the fact that reid is trying
to solve what is one of the most
pressing problems of today that you're
trying to solve which is
misinformation the
demise of local media so what the heck
can be done to solve this problem what
was your pitch to read and then what did
um so i we i mean we we took a very um
we took a very silicon valley ask a
purchase acronym of pilot pilot
different things and ideas scale what
works and fail quickly what doesn't and
something that i was personally obsessed
with for a long time from my early
journalism career and even just
being much younger and and sort of
watching how
you know we didn't call it
disinformation then but how the the bush
administration spread a lot of
propaganda to start a war after 9 11 i
was really obsessed with the role of
right-wing media in society in our
politics in our media ecosystem
generally and you know they've been
around for a really long time they they
built talk radio and fox news in
contrast to what they saw as a liberal
mainstream media don't think they were
necessarily wrong about sort of the
liberal kind of
leanings of the mainstream media at that
point in time you know and we're talking
about the 90s and and yet that pushed
mainstream media into a very defensive
position right lifting up both sides
being like we're not liberal
which started to you know pave the way
to being able to uphold lies um blatant
lies from from republican candidates and
elected officials and of course our
former president trump
as equivalent to facts from the other
side to try to show all sides and that
really did a disservice because it sowed
even more mistrust i think um among
people around who to trust and and and
so
in 2017 when i started acronym i had i
had written a research paper with a few
friends and colleagues um including eli
pariser who started i just want to stop
for a while because you completed that
thought in a way that um that i didn't
expect which was i thought you were
going to say that the rise of the
conservative media and the fox universe
or whatever pushed uh other
organizations like uh to the left but
what you said is that no it put pressure
on them to
uh to accept statements on both sides as
absolutely
equivalent so let me just go through
some of the different media orgs so you
were at cbs um and so i i think what
you're describing is like it would push
like the cbs's of the world or like the
abcs to to try and uh like take more
balanced tone and then like i i would
argue that it probably pushed like you
know the cnns of the world like probably
to be more of an oppositional
uh force to fox is that um i i think
that's right i mean it definitely we saw
after trump was elected cnn moved far to
the left because that's what would drive
engagement and views and clicks right it
always comes down to business
strategy i think but yeah we saw this
defensive posture we still see it today
it's still a real challenge in legacy
news organizations like the washington
post and the new york times uh but you
know we certainly saw in the lead up to
2016 with the coverage of hillary's
emails and then not seeing the
equivalent coverage of other things of
greater import or
even scandal um during the trump
administration so there's there is this
issue at hand and i don't have the
perfect solution for it but the real
issue was is that it created a real
vacuum where there was a right-wing
media driving conservative and
republican agenda yes a mainstream media
just trying to protect their existence
and so lifting up both sides and not
wanting to be seen as one side or the
other or liberal based on you know who
their backers were or what you know who
their producers voted for and then
democrats all they had left in their
arsenal because they didn't have either
media supporting them was paid
advertising billions of dollars in
television
wouldn't people say that the democrats
had like let's say i don't know what
time frame we're talking about but like
msnbc cnn and
sure i mean msnbc reaches a very small
small segment of like you're thinking
about you're talking about reach really
i'm talking about reach to
to the masses to americans yeah that
that there's that could be a different
city for decades right-wing media built
you know it's not just fox right it was
breitbart and now it it it's it's daily
caller daily wire ben shapiro
dan bongino like and and the the other
big thing that i think about is
conservative talk radio
i mean like that that is a massive
audience
and there's a local version of that
everywhere that's right
and so as they grew this infrastructure
on the right they started to really
drive the meta-narrative in this country
and put democrats at more of a defensive
posture without real
you know tools or weaponry to be able to
push back in an effective way or drive
their own narratives and this has gotten
even more complicated and more dangerous
because democrats
really do i mean there's always
exceptions to the rule but they are
incredibly concerned about always being
factual and and accurate and moral in a
way where we see the right they will say
anything if it drive click click drives
clicks and attention they intentionally
so
misha mistrust and hate and division and
fear in order to be able to drive their
agenda and then the media is just trying
to play both sides and try to make sense
of it to folks and and and the
right-wing media's influence has really
driven the narrative unless they lose
their footing which we've seen happen a
few times we saw in the pandemic
with trump's botched response quickly
republicans did not know how to pivot i
think we're seeing it with russia right
now because they're caught flat-footed
because so many of them were on the
record and supporting a president who
was
you know touting putin as a genius and
so outside of those types of
circumstances which are really powerful
they were able to push their wedge
issues into the mainstream
[Music]
i think our media is so tribalized now
that if someone makes a mistake along
the lines of what you're describing it's
not like viewers deserve them in droves
like you know like viewers are more
likely
to um
to stick around uh as long as they keep
getting the messages that they they want
like there's not like some absolute
standard it's like oh you've screwed up
like on on this issue so now you know i
don't believe in you anymore at this
point people will believe
uh their favored
outlet or individual or personality
that's right and then another challenge
to introduce which is what we're really
focused on solving for it good
information and courier is that millions
of americans do not watch cable news do
not subscribe to newspapers the vast
majority do not pay through pay walls
which is where traditional media has
moved online so
they are getting their news and
information scrolling their facebook
their instagram their tick tock feeds
one other thing i also want to say is
that like you you suggested something
that at one point i thought was true but
now unfortunately i don't which is you
suggested that democrats are like very
very locked into
being like you know
fact based and and diligent rigorous and
then the folks on the right will just be
sensationalistic and play like fast and
loose with the truth um i do think that
there is an equivalent version of that
on the left now where they will be like
very very inflammatory and like say
things like stretch things
where and it's been very
uncomfortable for me and a lot of people
i know because like you used to believe
that like hey if i you know subscribe to
this news outlet they'll be very very
responsible and you'll be like wait a
minute like i'm not sure i've actually
been getting like uh you know like well
i would describe that as farther to the
left at the far left truly because i i
do think that uh
i think that to your point about how
media has become so tribal they really
are small and very very passionate
active communities that are engaging in
those media yes and the vast majority of
the country including regular democratic
and republican voters but mostly
disengaged americans americans who are
not engaged or don't know why they
should be engaged in the political
process sure they're the audience that
i'm most concerned about because they
still are influenced by the halo of
disinformation that's reaching them
right because there isn't a counter to
it and disinformation is its most
most dangerous and effective in a vacuum
yeah so if there isn't other information
to counter it that reaches them where
they get their information
it wins right it's the you you hear a
lie three times it's the truth it
becomes incredibly hard to unravel that
and that's the e that's the environment
most americans are living in yes i agree
with so i 100 agree with the diagnosis
of that problem and i think about the
thousands of voters i met on the trail
maybe they weren't voters uh really it's
like the the random cleaning person at
the hotel in iowa it's like where they
getting their information
probably facebook that's right you know
right are there friends and neighbors
who are getting it from facebook or
getting it from tiktok or whatsapp and
they're not avid consumers of this stuff
they're not like oh every day i have to
see what the heck is happening like that
you know it's like living their lives
doing their thing and then occasionally
something filters through to them
because they'll turn on the radio in
their car or whatnot that's right and
i'm i'm fairly certain courier newsroom
the news organization that we started in
2019
is the first organization first news
organization of its kind that is
specifically focused on these passive
news consumers on reaching these
individuals that no legacy media is
focused on because they don't pay their
pay walls cable news and talk radio
aren't focused on because they aren't
tribal politically engaged i like it
activists trying to get information to
the non-super tribalized that's right
and it's super hard because guess what
they don't want political news or
information no they don't so you have to
like any business you have to give your
consumer what they want yeah and then
you know you hopefully are able to weave
in the vegetables as we call it i think
about the same stuff tara where i'm like
okay i'm going to try and give you
some uh meat and potatoes and then we'll
like slip some vegetables in there
that's right that's right you have to
and i mean that's how it's always been
done in this organization vegetable
filled generally i mean i
i need some more
candy sorry listeners sorry it's so
nutritious all the time
that's right but that's i mean that's
what our challenge is our so we have
editors and uh reporters and social
content producers in eight states now
the communities they serve we're in
arizona florida iowa michigan north
carolina pennsylvania virginia and
wisconsin great places to be continued
um you know you have to go where the
money wants you to go i and that's where
frankly the most disinformation spreads
and given our electoral college where uh
democracy kind of sits at stake in these
states and communities um and our
reporters and editors every day are
you know think they're living on these
platforms because that's where these
individuals are and the platforms are so
our primary channels of distribution are
um skimmable email newsletters
uh facebook instagram and we're about to
start piloting tech talk in a few states
um
yeah but you have to you have to really
lean on the creators because it's a
totally different format it's a totally
different format as someone who has a
thriving tick tock account
check me out at official andrew yang
there you go um so and that's the other
thing that's different about it so we
have a specific audience focus on like
other news orgs we go where they are
and our journalists aren't writing long
articles because this audience doesn't
read them so so what
do they read like what the yeah well
they don't read they skim so it is you
have to package the information you want
your audience to have
in a graphic a carousel an instagram
reel a tick tock video and it has to be
engaging and so you can't rely on a long
article or context or nuance and it's
sad like i'll be clear a lot of
journalists will like roll their eyes
when they hear this right but it's
actually respecting the audience and
their consumption habits it's not the
opposite i think it's very smart i think
it's you know savvy um but i'm still
trying to figure out like what is on
that instagram uh reel because you know
like you said they don't care about
politics on the daily so what do they
care about they care about what's going
on in their communities you mentioned
hyperlocal things earlier that's
absolutely true um they also care about
information that affects them so if you
center them in all of your content and
your reporting it's you know does this
is that whether is that entertainment
like what is that whether weather is
huge sports is huge sports is also
really unifying it's the other reason
that i decided to make curry or a local
news network which is harder in general
but it's because where you live in your
community is something that
that that binds you together you can
build bridges with people who you don't
agree with politically or in other ways
and it is like sports right you can be
on the same sports team but really
disagree about everything else so if i
live in a town in wisconsin
uh
is there like a version of courier news
for for me so up north news so every one
of the newsrooms has their own name
their own channels their own reporters
and voices and personalities wow so it's
a little like micro paper delivered via
social media and skimmable emails that's
right it's it's really it's it's
distribution focused because we
understand that you people don't come to
you anymore in this media environment
you have to go to them how many
journalists do you all employ so our
whole staff is about 65 full-time now
across the eight states and a small hq
team we centralize all of the data
analytics reporting we do our own media
buying in-house and the third part of
our model that is different from any
news organization i've ever heard of is
that we measure the impact of it
and that's really important
so our mission
is to make a more informed engaged in
representative america um that's the
mission of a lot of news organizations i
think they'd call it different things
but our model is is focused entirely on
the audience that isn't politically
engaged that is lower information
passive news consumers meeting them
where they are with information that is
actually relevant to them and then
understanding it if actually increases
their turnout in elections
and not for who they vote for but do
they turn out and across our eight
states 10 million americans voted for
the very first time in their lives after
2016.
it is critical to keep them informed and
engaged and voting because if they vote
a second or a third time they can turn
into lifetime voters if it was a one-off
because they were scared of the threat
of trump which a lot of those people
were they might not vote again and might
be even less engaged so this is really
the model is how do we keep them engaged
so on the measurement side we actually
run experiments we boost our news
coverage to these audiences we hold a
control group out like like a medical
randomized control treatment experiment
uh and then we look at the difference in
turnout between those different audience
segments after an election
wow
one of the things that really struck me
in 2020 so
i thought that people would must be
really tired of trump i mean iu was
botching kovid and i endorsed several
dozen candidates in swing districts
around the country thinking like oh this
is going to be a really great
opportunity love so many of these
candidates
and what stunned me was that turnout for
those candidates did go up many of them
were second time candidates
but then turnout surge on the other side
as well
and
the vast majority of the candidates that
i was
backing ended up getting swamped by
increased turnout for
trump in these locations
so when you talk about the 10 million
voters who voted for the first time in
these eight states it's probably on both
sides um and so
i is is it such that
courier news is uh
informing like a critical mass of voters
um on both sides or like or yeah it
sounds like it would be yeah i mean
we're really explicit about our values a
lot of people will call career
progressive because of those values i
think a lot of our values shouldn't be
partisan yeah what are those we believe
in science and climate change sure we
believe in reproductive rights and
freedom we believe in social and racial
justice and we believe in democracy and
we also believe that there needs to be a
strong democracy for there to be a free
and independent press in this country
among other things all the nice things
that we'd like to have and keep and so
we are explicitly pro-democracy and that
guides the editorial strategy of the
organization i think being pro-democracy
you should definitely not be uh partisan
or controversial
oh yeah yeah it really has and so and
what we really mean by pro-democracy
coverage too is accountability for
individuals elected officials leaders
in our states that are actually trying
to dismantle or make it harder to vote
for americans and that's a that's a huge
threat to this country and we know what
it can do in seeing what's happening in
eastern europe right now
[Music]
so you employ 65 people um many of them
though are journalists who are in these
communities or just all used to work for
state or local newspapers yeah and so
they they managed to be able to keep
doing their jobs so it's i'm sure a very
different job
um with you all it is and it's and we
we're constantly talking about this
internally too that this is hard because
i really believe that we're at the
forefront of where media news needs to
go writ large and we're really trying to
build new muscles because i went to
journalism school you're taught you know
that once you've reported something
right once you've shed light on
corruption you've published your story
your job is done right you've done good
there's a last mile problem there it and
it's why i was frustrated when i said
nothing happens after you right right
you're not closing the loop there you're
not making sure that it's reaching the
right people you don't know the impact
that the coverage is having and
most news organizations do believe and
it is their strategy that it's that is
we are here to inform the decision
makers and the elites and then that will
push policy change or push progress what
have you
the problem there is that there's a huge
swath of the the electorate that is not
getting informed at all and instead are
getting disinformed which then causes
barriers right to getting real change
done to having balanced government
having a functional government and so
our theory of the case is really if we
inform and we build trust with these
communities that other people are not
reaching out to
day in and day out that they will not
only be informed but empowered and feel
a sense of agency and participate i love
it i mean you're trying to to reach
people that right now most people don't
care about or try and reach you try and
reach them in a very modern tech savvy
way in a format that will actually be
additive to their lives and they're just
like on their instagram and then they're
like oh you know
like this
thing i mean i like love all of it
the thing that uh i found frustrating
when i was a uh what was called a social
entrepreneur you're calling it civic
entrepreneur is you look at it and
you're like okay i'll speak for myself
why not share a bit about
so
uh start an organization venture from
america to try and uh train aspiring
entrepreneurs uh and channel them to
cities
like st louis detroit baltimore new
orleans birmingham etc i don't know if
you know about
my
background and passed that way
now um
our budget uh after a number of years
was maybe in like the like
six to eight million dollar range
something along those lines
um which uh in the context of these
kinds of organizations is you know like
pretty good yeah but i grew to believe
that the problems i was trying to solve
were
ten thousand times bigger than that
because like my goal was not to
do something that i you know was proud
of
um which i did but it was to actually
help
uh the country through what i thought
was an historic economic transition
and then
i thought well how could you actually
help overhaul the economy in a
meaningful way
landed on something very dramatic like
universal basic income and then thought
well there's no way to do that that
doesn't involve
taking hold of the federal government
and so how do you do that run for
president united states so it's a very
linear path
i thought it was very logical my wife
agreed my wife didn't necessarily agree
anyway
um she came along yeah she i'd be doubt
no i mean she got on board uh she was on
board from the beginning but
yeah but what she really would she
really make that leap
uh so it's a sacrifice so in your case
like i feel like there's a massive
problem and you're tackling a sweet spot
in like a very very smart way um i do
feel like the problem's getting worse
around you all the time um so like right
now
uh there are advertisers on current
newsroom you are how are you structured
organized so so we are so we're a public
benefit corporation b corp love them we
are yes um and we did that for a number
of reasons i would have i would have i
mean there's a there's a huge movement
and a lot of exciting work in saving
local journalism that is very different
than what we're doing that's moving into
the c3 space right relying on
philanthropy we're going to have to be
right now because there aren't good
revenue i totally believe and agree with
that too
so we did a public benefit court because
we have a hybrid model so our primary
revenue stream is underwriting
mission-aligned organizations and
individuals who believe in our mission
who want to support it and they can fund
either specific areas of coverage like
our coverage of you know localizing the
impacts of climate change so when you go
into a town do you get local funders no
um so in we have in-state funders for
some of the newsrooms for sure because
you can cove you can underwrite coverage
areas specific news rooms if you care
about building that infrastructure in
your community or just the mission writ
large just because you support it so we
rely on those underwriters we disclose
our underwriters um it's a lot of
non-profit organizations and individuals
that believe in the work that is the
primary source of revenue so we call
impact revenue and then now that we've
built a large subscriber base across the
network we have over 620 000 subscribers
and social followers awesome um thank
you the team has worked really hard on
this and it's all about building trust
this is not an easy audience by
definition so now that we do have that
base audience we can start to monetize
we will never charge for our content to
these audience because that's defies
ourselves oh yeah
like these people don't pay for content
that way but now we can recruit sponsors
for the newsletters we want to hold
civic town hall events in all of our
states and communities have sponsors to
be able to support that work too and
start to diversify our revenue so we're
not relying on traditional ads because
you would need to drive people to
websites and our audiences do not read
articles so we're not going to drive
them through spammy memes like a lot of
media organizations do when it doesn't
serve our bottom line long term
congratulations
so it it
this is so if there's like a person
listening to this it's like ooh i love
this
um they don't live in one of these
states or or communities necessarily do
you have like
donors and grassroots donors
yeah you can go to couriernewsroom.com
follow us on twitter at courier newsroom
and you can you can see all of the
handles for all of the eight newsrooms
too to support them so anybody can
support the work on the website or any
of the state new websites and then um
we're also i'm really really excited
about this we're launching a content
organizing program this year another
thing most news organizations don't do
but to try to really bring more of the
great news coverage into the communities
in different spaces online where the
messaging apps and the facebook groups
and other things that are having
discussions about what's happening in
their school board meetings about what's
happening as it pertains to climate or
clean energy in their communities things
that affect them to make sure that we're
actually meeting them where they are
with this good information
and and this is definitely a plea to
your audience and and community is to
just evangelize the idea of sharing more
good information yeah because the other
side does this and and i don't mean to
say the other side as though we're one
side and the other but right
there's something where uh
lies uh are six times more likely to
spread quickly and powerfully
uh and we all know this like the more
zany and sensationalist and out there
and inflammatory like like that there
are a lot of people being like since
then
you also know the power of movement
building and trust right your community
trusts you they're gonna go to bat for
you they're gonna take actions and i
think a lot of people in this country
are really concerned about
disinformation because they have family
members they've lost to it yeah they
have friends and and so it is a very
very simple and easy thing anyone can do
they just understand that it matters you
know posting something on your instagram
story or on your tick tock you don't
know how many people who trust you and
know you from some walk of life are
actually going to have their mind
changed by that and i think it really is
just about building that muscle because
the instinct is to is to share the most
salacious or you know the the most kind
of wild or conspiracy driven stuff
so uh
here's my sense of things and you
probably have some again updated numbers
so
uh over 2000 newspapers have gone out of
business locally
uh
the journalism industry as a profession
is just getting decimated i don't know
what that that set of numbers is but you
know you have like tens of thousands of
journalists by hundreds of thousands
that have left their jobs and exited the
field which by the way on the record
makes me
sad because
i think uh
journalists
are for the most part like just
folks who like to write and wanted to
share stories about the community and
like it's not that lucrative or
profession for the most part nobody gets
into journalism to make money yeah and
so uh so some some things about
young andrew is that like when i was
very young i read a lot of uh dogs and
dragons and science fiction novels the
fantasy novels that sort of thing um and
so there's a period when you know i was
like writing very terrible like juvenile
versions of that and then there were
like there's a point where you're like
oh maybe i'd want to write and so then
there's like a mo like i've always liked
and admired journalists um and then
seeing them just get all uh fired or
whatnot like has made me sad now some
some people
and this is also something that's
tempered me
so
uh i ran for president interacted with
dozens of journalists like different
levels i ran for mayor interact with
dozens of journalists
um
and i've had journalists do really
shitty things uh
so if i i can imagine yeah
and so that there is like part of you
now where it's like like my
uh natural sympathy for journalists like
over time has been like you know because
i know there are some people who like
frankly like mistrust journalists
and i'm someone who typically has wanted
to give people
the benefit of the doubt
but then i've seen like you know these
distortions
and
if i'm going to be favorable about or
generous about it it would be like look
you have a field where people are now
under these enormous
pressures
economic and professional and otherwise
and that is going to end up driving
worse behavior
over time i was going to say it comes
down to incentives right and i do i do
think i mean mike i'll just speak from
my personal experience i have a lot less
uh a lot fewer bones to pick with local
and state journalists i've ever met than
national political journalists they have
a very different agenda but it does it
comes down to incentives they're
incentivized to drive clicks and shares
and engagement on their content and it
is worse for these national types
because they're trying to get to like
these broad internet audiences where
it's like the local paper it's like they
they're not used to trying to get that's
right a bajillion clicks on their stuff
another story uh that i'll i'll relate
which is uh in my last book
which uh was campaigning around iowa and
new hampshire and interacting with
dozens of local journalists but those
stuff like the newsrooms were
disappearing i'd show up
and it would be like a half empty
building or two-thirds empty building
and the people that were there like
someone said to me it's like this is
gonna be the last season when you
actually even have like local
journalists who like follow a candidate
around to tell their stories in new
hampshire iowa or whatnot and that made
me feel really bad too
i also have in the story that
uh the major iowa paper that all the
presidential candidates wanted to spend
time with was the des moines register
which as you know was purchased by uh
hedge fund
during the midst of that campaign so
imagine like i was hanging out with this
des moines register reporter and then
she confided in me that all of her
colleagues are worried about their jobs
because they just got bought by
um you know i forget which hedge fund
was it's in my book
um and and so you you really think about
just how completely screwed up this
landscape is
[Music]
so to complete my thought you have
thousands of local papers tens of
thousands of journalists get jettisoned
um in my mind you have this
for-profit business model that just
doesn't work anymore um and
and so you need to substitute in
uh
philanthropy
in my mind it has to wind up being
publicly financed to be at the proper
scale
um so there was legislation still is
being proposed a local journalism
sustainability act that would channel
not even that huge amount of money in
the scheme of things maybe like a
billion two billion uh something along
those lines what do you think the size
of the whole is
um
gosh that's a great question because i
spend so much of my time focused on
some of the challenges and gaps in the
existing model and i think there's a lot
of incredible efforts
to save and bolster the existing model
that are not also addressing how that
model is still broken oh yeah i think
that that's different layers you can
tell i'm frustrated by that but it's
like look like you know you're freaking
hemorrhaging it's like you know hey i
can make you bleed a little bit less
it's like yeah that's solving the
problem it's like no like well
you have to do it all is the answer
unfortunately we have to do it all this
it's just a difficult question to answer
the scale of the problem because there
there are these different layers to it
and there's an amazi there's amazing
efforts like the american journalism
project and amazing startups like
chalkbeat which i know that you've had
folks
absolutely and that are doing really
really incredible work to save this
industry and and really address it in
thoughtful ways report for america is
another one that is staffing and
subsidizing local journalists and
communities these are all so important i
do think public financing needs to be a
piece of the solution too it is
the the challenge before us though is
not just saving local journalism it's
shifting how we do journalism in this
country and how we think about
distribution
given distribution has changed and it's
not it's not a real new or novel
challenge it's happened every time new
media has been introduced right from
like the printing press through
television talk radio what have you the
internet social media it's going to
continue to adapt and change and media
is now so increasingly decentralized
that we need to have also more
investment in innovative models that
focus on communities that aren't the
highest
income consumers that's right and we
don't because all of the startups that
i'm hearing about that get big money
like the you know the new ben smith one
i'm not gonna remember the name which is
gonna be a problem for them there's a
word there semaphore maybe but like
there are these new startups and and
they're not bad necessarily but they're
all focused on elite audiences and high
information consumers meanwhile our
democracy's on the brink
and we're not doing enough as a society
as a government as a democratic party to
really focus on this information divide
and gap and these these efforts
still feel too piecemeal to me and too
small yes and i mean that's sort of what
the point i'm getting yes that's exactly
right and like i i don't expect courier
to be a silver bull because there isn't
going to be one or a solution we did
build it in a way that was very
intentionally scalable because we need
more scalable it does feel like people
should be just pumping funds into
courier so that instead of
being 65 people it's 60 500 people
and instead of you know like these eight
papers it's like 800 or 8 000. we we
would welcome that that's not really the
environment
because there's still a real learning
curve there though right it's well so
this is one of the things too i learned
you know the the uh through experience
with venture from america so check it
out i'm a social entrepreneur you know
i'm doing my thing it's like 2011
hanging out with awesome people 2012
2013. so then you get an audience with a
billionaire and reid hoffman is like an
exceptional billionaire in in my view
read often actually got donated to
venture for america um but you get an
audience with a billionaire and then
you're like hey you know if i can just
convince this billionaire my thing
and then like all my problems will be
over
and then um and then that this
billionaire uh it turns out that if
you're a billionaire you don't
necessarily operate in increments of
like you know
uh 5 million or 10 million like you
might operate in increments of like one
or two hundred thousand so then like you
you get like one or two hundred thousand
from said billionaire and then you're
like okay like i'm like glad for that
but you know like like is that going to
be able to solve like you know this
problem and i'm just going to throw a
couple numbers at what i'd like you to
estimate what the journalism problem is
um so let's say you have like 2 000
local papers that are out of business
and you could like you know replace some
of their key functions the way chalkbeat
is like on the cheap and the rest of it
but you'd still be looking at
you know in my mind let's say like a
million bucks
um per so you're you're looking at um uh
you know very quickly
uh like a couple billion like it's at
least
it's at least a couple
it's at least a couple billion dollar
annualized problem now can you so so
that like and then you'd be like hey can
i get some revenue sources to defray
pieces of that couple billion like you
know
um maybe it's a three or four billion
dollar problem you can get one or two
billion in revenue whatever it is um
maybe these numbers are off by like uh
and but this is the probably the minimal
as you say like this would be like the
lowest thing
and contrast that to a trillion dollar a
year disinformation economy that we live
in yeah competing with exactly it's like
what what is this is one thing i'm like
very very i'm working on
i'm frustrated by it because i've been
in the rooms and like you say they're
like piecemeal and hodgepodge and
different people doing different things
and they're they're like folks who are
trying to bring it together but even as
they bring it together
um it's being under invested in
and and so you you look at it like
you know so some of the questions i
asked when i was running for president
it's like hey like you know if you had
to put a price tag on climate change
like what would you put it on and people
like you know you think about that one
and it's like you know and then i tell
you for context like the u.s economy is
22 trillion per year so then like if you
had to throw and then people could come
up with just about any number for
climate change and it'd be right because
by the way you know it's also going to
kill people
and the rest of it um so then it'd be
like hey what's the price tag you'd put
on democracy
i'm asking this question every day now
yeah because nothing else matters if we
don't if we don't protect democracy in
this country like everyone's business
interests are tied to this every
philanthropist interests are tied to
this it's if you don't have a
functioning democracy are you going to
be able to address
climate change or any other stuff that
you're plowing like hundreds of millions
of dollars into absolutely not and
that's that's also that's the
disinformation ecosystem right it's so
much bigger than politics
it's democracy it's public health as we
know from vaccine disinformation it's
public safety it's climate it affects
all of this like if you're not
addressing the information ecosystem
problem and incentive structure in this
country you're not addressing any of
those problems yeah in a meaningful way
yeah it's a a very compelling case like
i make a version of that case then you
circulate around and you find some
people and then some people are like you
know what tara this is great stuff
two hundred thousand dollars hold on and
then then you're you're grateful because
you're like well you know but at the
same time you're like you know like this
like
you know it's slipping away and we've
got like a couple billion dollar hole
and it needs to be subsidized and i do
believe also that there's a massive
market opportunity in local news that's
coming and so it's the startup needs to
grow and scale now when we don't have a
lot of time and there is this urgency
around our democracy and
and then i do believe that it will be
able to pay for itself because i think
the ecosystem will continue to shift and
change that there
100
are ways for these local
publications to at a minimum be break
even the problem right now is that if
you have a public company it's not
enough to break even you have to show
like let's call it double digit margins
and then that's not enough because you
have to show a growth rate
of x and so if you are a
financial operator you come in you buy
the des moines register uh you look up
and be like what's that you're breaking
even well that's terrible like time to
fire
like
these folks and sell the real estate and
then we'll like you know and this is a
different rabbit hole we definitely
don't have time to go down fully but we
don't have good capital instruments in
this country for actual impact where
you're you're not actually driving for a
financial return you're driving for a
social impact return we have different
models and you hear about it but at the
end of the day it still ends up coming
down to that financial return and we're
at a point in our society and in our
democracy right now where we actually
need our elites and our billionaires to
subsidize this work at scale for the
foreseeable future
and they don't need to cover the entire
cost there will definitely be revenue
streams but i think that there is a
culture shift that needs to occur here
and i and i do believe that it's it's
coming close to the point where we hit
rock bottom and it happens out of fear
and urgency but we're not quite there
yet i've got two things i'm going to
pitch to you
well so one
is called the impact genome project have
you heard of this thing i don't think so
all right so what you were just
suggesting just now is like look
everything is around financial returns
it turns out some of the most important
things don't have an immediate like
dollar amount attached to them but if
you don't invest in them we're all
[ __ ] um totally agree uh and so one of
the big ideas that i was championing was
like look like we have to actually start
measuring outcomes like human-centered
outcomes yes where instead of saying new
kpis yes new kpis
um so i called it the american scorecard
and you can include healthy democracy on
there and then like what is the return
on that the the early effort in this
space is social impact bonds which is
like i'm gonna invest in an outcome so
if you can like help kids like learn
better or whatnot like that's worth ten
thousand bucks a pop to me so i'm gonna
give you a billion and then you can
demonstrate you did it for
like like a thousand kids now the social
impact bond market is still relatively
like nascent and like under capitalized
to your point
um so
the impact genome project awesome
entrepreneur um in chicago who is trying
to say like look don't invest in
activities invest in outcomes or results
um so just like you know it could be a
private company it could be a non-profit
uh that that addresses it and so one of
the reasons they do this is because
there's a sense that we have that i
happen to co-sign on is that like a lot
of our government operations are not
very results-oriented and it's just like
politician shows up cuts the ribbon is
like hey i did this thing
started this program it's like did the
program deliver who the hell knows
someone looks at it later and is like oh
no like rebranded do this and like no
one knows whether anything happened and
american people are like oh i don't know
if i believe this stuff
at this point so the impact genome
project is trying to say like look
everyone should just be trying to
measure the outcome of the result so i
just had a vision which is that
you have an economy of the future that
has uh multiple things you can invest in
um
and then
uh now i happen to believe that the
government should be
capitalizing this at like a very high
level um i think the government should
be publicly subsidizing local journalism
to the tune of billions of dollars and
i'd have zero problem with that now
there are a lot of folks who you know
dislike that um because they think like
oh the government can't be a part of
well what happens when trump is
president again if he is he owns the
meeting and i'm just like look and my my
uh i mean there are a lot of arguments
that i think are you know would work but
one of the things i say is like look
town library do you have a problem with
the town library
public
that is what the town paper is the
equivalent of really um you're just
conditioned to think that the media is a
for-profit business and the library or
the post office is not it's like at this
point like the local paper is the town
library or the equivalent um it should
be with protections right and safeguards
around it yeah well the other thing i
could say is like hey like uh uh npr pbs
like do you really think someone in
washington's like telling the local npr
station what their editorial choice is
like no you know you know i mean or you
could say like hey look other countries
you know like there are like all sorts
of the these
models so so there should be a massive
public investment in various goals
whether it's climate resiliency local
journalism right put these mental health
out we need to have a healthy populace a
healthy
environment a healthy society
with the major context being that right
now we have
untold
stock market
wealth and record highs and then our
quality of life is just degrading and
disintegrating which ends up leading to
authoritarianism especially if you have
a two-party system that artificially
ends up empowering like you know like uh
we're on a fast track yeah we we've set
up structures that are facilitating this
descent that's right uh
and there are people like you are trying
to make things better but um you know
like it's the the the struggle you have
um is something i'm familiar with is
like hey like we have to just be doing
more faster
more faster yes
like take the risk and like
pile in yeah yeah and just and i really
do think it comes down to people really
understanding the roi around democracy
on this stuff and that there isn't going
to be one solution everybody's looking
for one solution there's not going to be
one solution well you need to invest in
a lot of different things that are
trying to do this work with the real
purpose and mission at heart of it
well you're certainly a piece of the
puzzle i mean like i you you're saying
like look i'm not the silver bullet but
like i'll tell you you are a bullet
but also you you know when you're a
first mover in anything it's hard and
you're going to get all the criticism
we're closer to a silver bullet than uh
than most anything no but the goal is
because if you had like a revved up
courier newsroom it's like where there
be more i mean that's still the goal
right we're a lot more revved up than we
were and we made our first acquisition
time back to your iowa story iowa's
starting line they were going to close
their doors oh wait there's a courier
network no way is that pat reiner pat
reinert he's the editor he's been the
editor he was the founder of it came
into the network and and where we where
we agreed is he's like look the model we
were doing weren't working people are
just getting flooded with disinformation
in iowa so it doesn't matter how much
accountability journalism we do if we're
not actually informing iowans oh th this
makes me so happy because i don't know
if you know like me and pat hung out
yeah pat's hung out with all the
presidential candidates you're not no
but but now i hung out with pat i mean
tara i'm like yeah i know these other
voice now but like i
see them all over the place and i have a
real fondness for that's fantastic he
inspired me for many years before i
started career with what he was doing in
iowa and then you were able to come back
and acquire him
he wrote a blog post about how they were
going to have to shut their doors i
cried i called him and we figured it out
and that was last year look at that
saving our first acquisition it brought
us to eight news firms saving local
journalists trying doing our best so i
guess now your crew is rooting for iowa
to stay the first the nation
i thought we did away with caucuses it
would be good for a starting line
another thing for democracy um yeah no
but uh but it's also really exciting to
i mean exciting and terrible but to be
in a state where uh you know it's it's
blood really red in iowa and i actually
believe that our model can make a huge
difference in areas that aren't as
saturated like the battleground states
with other media and investments this is
another point i made that like really
that like does
fire me up
so obama won iowa yes uh uh this is like
a very very purple state
94 percent white
rural
um
now it's uh r plus eight or so um there
are democratic members of congress cindy
axne
uh and democratic leaders and candidates
many of whom i like and consider friends
but that environment is just going
redder and redder um and
the democrat you know the response to
the democratic party to that
like who cares who cares we're gonna go
to arizona or georgia that's right um
because those environments are more
diverse that's right uh and i hear this
and i think well like why don't you like
go to iowa and explain to them why they
don't matter anymore
uh and by the way this is just gonna
speed up
racialized polarization in our country
where you're going to look up and say
uh rural white areas well can't win here
you know like let's just go to like it
like i'm fearful that's happening across
the board generally right like there's
starting to be plans in motion because
roe v wade is likely to be overturned in
june about there's just going to be
states where women can get an abortion
in this country in states where you
cannot and and and that's where planning
is coming into place about like okay
we're going to have we think we're
divided now
when it comes to this we are we are
absolutely it's why i left politics
frankly it was a big reason as i felt
like i was part of the problem of
polarization political ads do that they
continue to so mistrust people don't
want to be they don't feel a part of the
system they feel they're being lied to
they feel they're being taken advantage
of that's those feelings are really real
yeah and and to be an effective
political operative you have to activate
that stuff yes and and and also just to
be an affected elected official
government official you have to
understand where people are and it isn't
about politics when you're governing
except it is in america today and i
think that
there's always just been over investment
in these states that that obviously
matter because of the electoral college
but
but
the lack the moving from one to another
and leaving the other behind and and not
actually deploying a 50-state strategy
to build bridges and everything
the argument i made is like look hey
democrats if you are losing iowa and
ohio states that you used to be
competitive and win in not that long ago
12 years ago
and now you're losing by eight nine
points
uh maybe the problem is that things have
gotten worse for the people in those
states
uh and the stuff you've been talking
about is not really like you know doing
the trick or helping um and so for me it
was like like maybe you should be
investing in like that reality and oh by
the way like you know that that would be
great for the country it'd be great for
your party be great for everyone um but
the the democratic party is not actually
geared to try and improve the lives of
iowans or ohioans um the democratic
party is geared to eke out a win in the
next election
uh and so then they're they're going to
drift towards uh
arizona or georgia like the where the
demographics are shifting where things
are becoming more urban
uh and so the the lives of the people
just become you know like unimportant
um and that that was something that
troubled me greatly it's put that way
it's like like at this point like how do
you expect that to
to change and i congratulate you for
saying like look i'm going to put down
the partisan hat and create this
unifying
like wholesome local news organization
that's going to try and meet people
where they are and deliver information
to them in a way that's additive to
their lives and improves their
information environment yes but like i'd
imagine like actually just like improves
their sense of local engagement because
there's like a local publication that
cares about them and and you know will
notify them about what's going on in
their own community and also just making
sure some of the information of what
government does good for communities
when it does good reaches people
journalists don't have an incentive to
cover that you're trained not to you're
contrarian and yet that also builds
mistrust like the trust crisis in
america right now is really really
really dangerous like people don't trust
one another they don't trust
institutions that's what's going to lead
to authoritarianism yeah this dynamic
you just described too is like a bit of
like
so if you talk to journalists too about
this public financing the rest of it um
one of the responses you'll get is like
no like the journalist's job is to speak
truth to power which is this adversarial
stance you're talking about so if like a
random government official does
something positive and it's like oh you
know like it made these people's lives
better it's like i don't care about that
right like where's the gotcha where's
the negative yes that's exactly right
yeah and it's a huge problem yeah yeah
because we really don't and then it
becomes reliant on the parties to
advocate their own cases and that's not
also how it should be either facts are
facts the truth should get out when
something is good for a community people
should know it right it's like there was
a recent poll a few weeks ago where
americans feel like they're doing better
economically right but they feel like
the country's economy is going in the
wrong direction and they also had
absolutely no awareness that joe biden
has created more jobs as president
than past presidents like their that
information is not reaching people at
all because it's not the controversial
story line or angle that journalists are
going to drive more clicks or that their
editors are going to ask of them there
is a real bias towards like the negative
the skepticism the sowing or mistrust
type of story i i'm not here to promote
joe biden's policies it's like no you're
not you're here to get the facts about
what those policies are going to do to
these communities to these individuals
though because they have a right to know
and honestly it comes down to what is
the information that is factual accurate
honest that that will help people make
informed decisions at the polls yeah it
won't persuade them but it will let them
have the information they need to make a
decision about what matters to them yeah
one of the most discouraging uh
facts uh of the of the recent past was
my interview with derek thompson a
journalist at the atlantic about how now
your perception of the economy is almost
strictly based upon
uh how you feel about the party in power
and like and then i was like oh wow like
then we're really sunk if i i can't
actually convince you that things are
better
based on them being better right you
know
like they are better and i can't
convince you of that because of who's
behind it yeah yeah yeah that's a rough
world so that's why we'll have a new
party right
that's how we'll have a new party that's
right
um well congratulations uh on taking on
a very very important problem that
actually is driving just about every
other
uh problem
um
and i hope that people pile in and get
behind you
and courier newsrooms uh to the level
that they should
um because it's awesome um and
uh you know like i'm just pumped that
you're here to be able to share
your work with us
uh and we wish you like freaking you
know like all of the support and
resource you need
thank you so much andrew i really really
appreciate it and i hope to your whole
community too just the one simple thing
to take away is to just share more good
information and not think that the
people in your community are already
getting it because the odds are that
they're not and i think that that that's
where people can really make a
difference before we have
better models reaching folks share good
information when tara mcgowan thank you
so much taryn really congratulations
it's awesome thank you andrew really
really great to be here
[Music]
you